[Music]
you may remember these songs as huge
summer hits from the last five years but
each of them share something else in
common they were all crowned billboards
song of the summer yeah the song of the
summer isn't just the one you keep
hearing on the beach it's a real
competition determined by specific data
points every year billboard measures the
summers most popular songs between
Memorial Day and Labor Day based on
radio play sales and streaming the song
that stays at the top of the Hot 100
through the season is crowned the winner
but on June 29 billboard is throwing a
wrench into things that's the day the
entire hot 100 rating system will start
to give more weight to paid streaming
services and less weight to free or
ad-supported services so why should we
care well the change to billboards
algorithm may impact the types of songs
that hit the top of the charts and it
may put a new kind of pressure on
artists who are already pushed to
produce songs that cater to streamers
listening habits the second someone's
like we should show them the intro
because of skip rate I'm like oh so why
is billboard pushing ahead with this
change well it comes down to the age-old
debate of whether consumers should have
to pay for their music to vary things
the idea is that a free youtube play
shouldn't mean as much as a play from
someone who pays $10 a month for a
Spotify subscription under the current
formula YouTube views are weighted
heavily so sizzle worthy videos can
skyrocket to the top of the charts yeah
this is
you know this is America is a great
example of that he debuts the sign
literally just five days of consumption
everyone's talking about the meaning of
the video boom right out of the gate
you've got 60 million streams that's
enough maybe without radio or sales if
the numbers are high enough to have a
number-one debut the YouTube effect has
impacted the charts for the first time
in over 20 years
2018 has already seen three number-one
debuts on the Hot 100
all of which had hundreds of millions of
YouTube views including God's plan by
Drake God's plan in addition to buzz
worthy videos certain genres of music
that are favored by young people tend to
perform better largely because this
demographic disproportionately strains
for free on YouTube and Beyond hip-hop
generally tends to be a more youthful
oriented genre that preference may have
helped Justin Bieber Luis FONSI and
daddy Yankees Desp Osito take last
year's song of the summer crown it also
explains how as of June 19 the top four
songs on the Billboard Hot 100 were
hip-hop or rap songs but despite all the
charts and rule changes artists still
believe the song of the summer is about
something deeper
just ask o me who won billboards
competition in 2015 with cheerleader
I think whatever song that stimuli is
that that that emotion that make you
feel relaxed make you feel like you're
on a holiday
you